One of the great things that is
lacking in most of our companies is that
they are not teaching us how to lead.
And leadership is a skill like any other.
It is a practicable, learnable skill
and it is something that you work on
it's like a muscle.
If you practice it all the days
you will get good at it
and you will become a strong leader.
If you stop practicing
you will become a weak leader.
Like parenting
everyone has the capacity to be a parent
doesn't mean everybody wants to be a parent
and doesn't mean everybody should be a parent.
Leadership is the same.
We all have the capacity to be a leader
doesn't mean everybody should be a leader
and it doesn't mean everybody wants to be a leader.
And the reason is because
it comes at great personal sacrifice.
Remember you're not in charge.
You're responsible for those in your charge.
That means things like
when everything goes right,
you have to give away all the credit.
And when everything goes wrong,
you have to take all the responsibility.
That sucks.
It's things like
staying late to show somebody what to do.
when something does actually break,
when something goes wrong
instead of yelling and screaming
and taking over
you say, "try again"
when the overwhelming pressures are not on them,
the overwhelming pressures are on us.
At the end of the day
great leaders are not responsible for the job
they're responsible for the people
who are responsible for the job.